un bâtiment en ruine voici ce qu'il
reste du collège visé par une frappe
russe à Orif dans la région de zapporija
l'établissement servait de centre d'aide
humanitaire selon le ministère de la
Défense ukrainien il aurait été ciblé
lors d'une distribution faisant
plusieurs morts et blessés sur place les
sauveteurs tentent de déblayer la zone
dans des conditions difficiles
constantes et des frappes aériennes
incessantes à orifi aujourd'hui une
nouvelle frappe aérienne a eu lieu non
moins du site de la précédente
à travers l'Ukraine les civils tentent
de se protéger comme il le peuvent des
bombardements à 1000 km dorés qui dans
la ville de vive Mirka n'a eu que
quelques instants pour mettre sa famille
à l'abri
c'était la nuit la sirène du raid aérien
retentit il y a eu des bruits de verres
brisés nous savions que la mort nous
poursuivait j'ai mis des chaussures à
mes enfants en toute hâte
avec ses enfants elle a vu sa maison
s'effondrer sous ses yeux frappés par un
missile russe
a eu lieu nous étions allongé sur le sol
je leur ai crié de se mettre à terre
au total plus de 30 maisons ont été
touchées dans cette frappe ainsi que des
bureaux un campus étudiant et des
dizaines de voitures faisant de cette
attaque la plus importante de la guerre
contre les infrastructures civiles de la
ville
depuis le début de la contre-offensive
l'armée ukrainienne a annoncé avoir
repris 169 km2 sur le front de Sud